it's great to have Frank mink back on
the show Frank is a former neo-nazi who
we were introduced to when a couple of
years ago Frank and I were both
scheduled to be on dr. Drew's show on
headline news and when they were
interviewing Frank my picture popped up
as the person being interviewed and it
was my mug shot with a Frank mink former
neo-nazi up on the screen it was really
weird I was one of the more clean-cut
former neo-nazis that dr. Drew had ever
interviewed in any case we met Frank
through that mix-up and he's been on the
show a bunch of time since Frank here's
what I want to start with with you what
is it about Donald Trump that has
interested white supremacists white
separatist neo-nazi types so much is it
policy is it his persona why do they
like him not it's really not the it
right now mainly was mainly is that
their one getting the black guy out of
there and then his closest ally who was
the woman you know it's I mean they've
been so against anything Obama now that
I mean they they would vote in anything
go vote in a ham sandwich if they could
if it would be anything that would get
you know the Obamacare out something
that they're so afraid of this they're
continuing giving black people poor
black people health care and I mean it's
they're so we you see the rage when they
bring up Obamacare and in a lot of the
white supremacist groups just feel that
it's as the this is the best way to get
rid of all that it was getting Donald
Trump in because hands-down if Donald
Trump was just standing by himself and
this was all they wouldn't vote for him
they wouldn't like him they would hate
him he's part of the the TV world he's
part of it and then you know he's not
what they were a picture as a good
leader but they're just so willing to
get the one out that they're going to
take will take Obama they'll take care
um for right now so in your sense a lot
of the attraction is not necessarily
specific policies that a so-called white
supremacist or white separatist would
like but it's more that right now but
Trump was the white guy who was running
and he was against a lot of the stuff
Bhama did and that that sort of enough
and it doesn't even really matter the
specifics of what it is that Trump
stands for three because they did one
thing well there's two things the
birther they kind of were all they like
that part and then his immigration was
definitely the second so the one thing
that they did match up on they loved and
they nobody else was that they felt
talking about that type of stuff cuz I
mean even though he's not a
working-class guy he kind of talks
working-class even though he's the most
furthest thing from a working-class guy
yeah so that's again that's the the
little images of stuff you know he kind
of mean kind of rude her you know you
would say things into the white
working-class guy who's feel Nathan
being kicked around for last couple
years it just matched kind of the way
that they felt and drank when you were
more when you were an active neo-nazi
and you were associating with neo-nazis
and white supremacists did any of them
really think that there might be a
president someday that would really sort
of be supportive of their views or was
it a different standard work was more
like if we can get anybody who's just
kind of anti-immigration and more of
like a hey you know white people are
good people too type of populist uh uh
rhetoric that that was really all they
could hope for and it would be more of
like an opportunity to maybe do
something did any of them really think
there might someday be a white
supremacist president not me we never
thought that we thought that this
country have to be separated to get that
so this for this to have but then again
we were I was in the error before Fox
News I mean back then we thought every
news agency was against us and I am you
know they're starting to be a certain
news organizations that are that are
supposedly legitimized legitimate and
they're they're saying the same red I
mean god I would just put a bunch of
formers the so last week we were all
talking about this the election and all
former white supremacist and right-wing
extremists and we were saying about how
again Fox News and a lot of the Trump
rhetoric that is kind of being said and
and stuff from the all right is just
recycled what we said
five years ago except for a took the
word Jew out and they put the word
federal government in where instead of
taking saying the n-word or black people
they say the entitlement being people
that entitlement righted it basically
saying the same exact thing we did
word-for-word except they took one word
out is that that may be why remember is
that may be why Trump's rhetoric has
been appealing to white supremacists
because even though he's not using like
you're saying the n-word or referring to
Jews that the entire vocabulary and
presentation maybe is making white
supremacist say he sounds like some of
the stuff that we like even if he's
using slightly different words that
maybe the appeal but yeah because like
we know that there is an appeal there
because they're excited he want but I
know that from listening when Trump was
first running they didn't like them but
you know this was it you know if I'm
finally gonna win and have to win I want
to win this way and so they're this
accepting of it but yes I mean again
it's that rhetoric it's that beating if
you step back and everyone starts to
listen to what they're saying over there
on the right and the far right the
alt-right they're saying it's all
fear-based they're coming to take what's
ours you get us back in power and we'll
keep it I mean it's if you just listen
listen for it it's an everything they
say is that those people and I think I
talked to you about this before on when
I first got recruited in a movement it's
a bait and switch they tell you come be
part of you come join this group be
proud of your heritage be proud of what
you are you go to these meetings you go
to Bible studies we never talk about
being proud to be in anything will we
say look at what they're doing look at
what the others are doing
look how they're destroying ours it's
always about the other people so this is
the same thing so when I listen to the
rhetoric on their side it's I mean it's
just mind-boggling and I and I'm hoping
and what I'm trying to do is keep a
historical checklist in my head and
let's go back to the 30s in Germany and
see if these you know start checking on
somebody's checklist I know everyone's
kind of afraid of the Hitler reference
but yeah I mean it is there is some some
some things that make me concerned so
well the comparison I made Frank was
more towards like the strongman a Latin
American dictator types that pretend to
be left-leaning populist and how there's
a lot of you know the attack on the
integrity of the legal system attacks on
the integrity of intelligence agencies
but what I wanted to talk with you about
next is Donald Trump on paper right if
we want to talk about a family like the
immediate family and Judaism Donald
Trump has a Jewish daughter a Jewish
son-in-law who is clearly one of his
most trusted confidant and advisors
Jewish grandchildren how is it that the
white supremacists have been most
excited by the presidential uh the
president-elect now previously
presidential candidate who actually has
the most Jews in their family of I
believe any any recent president how do
they explain that a way to say Trump is
still our guy well even say reason I
would probably say ever I think so yeah
I so and again um there was just the the
rally and this is where everyone's been
talking about this worthy spencer's up
there you know he'll Trump out Trump in
her suit saluting with the Sieg Heil
yeah even if you go into that speech
that he gave he even says Trump isn't
really our guy like he is very
supportive of Israel like he's an
unbelievable supporter of Israel and so
again it's kind of like I'm starving so
I'm going to eat this food and I might
have to you know to a couple bones to
get to it but right now that's the best
thing that we got I mean he is he is the
closest ally even if he says he's not so
how their acceptance of it is they have
no other choice but they're so like his
joke was I did the sick how because I
knew piss off liberals that was it
that's what he said that's not at this
quote I we all did that just going to
piss off liberals tell me what kind of
person has no humanity to know that
saluting like that
so means to other people six million
people dying in a Holocaust what person
with no compassion or empathy would say
that that's a joke and that's the people
you're dealing with so for me to
rationalize how they're rationalizing
dealing with try
I don't know I can sometimes use can't
rationalize stupid that's interesting so
it's not so much that they're
specifically saying they don't care
about the fact that Donald Trump has a a
number of Jewish family members it's
more that they're saying this is the
best possibility to even open the door
to the type of sort of nationalist
nativist ideology that we like it's not
that they're ignoring it it's that
they're sort of saying we can't really
worry about that because Trump is the
closest thing we'll ever get to someone
that might legitimize our movement and
here's the thing that's being talked
about oh yes and then and then with that
all being said they believe in this when
I say that they mean that the white
supremacist movement the militia
movement those type of groups they
believe that Obama had been letting
black life matters right in streets this
is their rhetoric that they've been
turning a blind eye to this they think
that Trump is going to turn a blind eye
to some of the stuff they're going to
pull and what some of this we're gonna
pull they're gonna they're gonna start
taking up some hills up in Michigan and
they're gonna say this is our Hill which
is no federal government land now this
is ours and you know just like I tried
to do in Oregon right those guys got off
so now people have seen we could do this
we're not going in trouble they're gonna
start taking up hills and taking up
little properties and take on little
areas you know bub Misha troit where
there's little issues and there's you
know they look down AC Detroit bit
scares them so we don't want no one up
here from Detroit what do we know what
that means
we only know black people up here women
so we won no federal government up here
neither no Jews so and they're gonna
take up their little hills and then you
have people down in Arizona
down on the border you know the
Minuteman hey we're gonna take up this
area desired federal government gonna
come in here and they're little
standoffs and you know hopefully back
down or a while we got Native Americans
not too far from where I am right now
we're being sprayed with pepper spray
because there are pipeline going to damn
well water source you know right race
well that that was you answered what was
going to be my last question which is
what can we expect in what way can we
expect these groups to try to take
advantage of the trump presidency and
you you spelled it out Frank mink former
no not there you are always great to
talk to you Frank thank you so much but
explode thank you